[Applaudissements]
ça fait longtemps qu'on vous a pas vu
merci de m'avoir envoyé un petit Bristol
comme ça j'ai pu répondre
et je l'ai surtout défendu on va dire et
maintenant vous
a changé quand même maintenant
à Bruxelles
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Charles Charles
Jean-Michel ne m'a pas manqué
c'est qui ton préféré
moi je l'aime beaucoup moi je t'aime
beaucoup t'aime tout le monde qui est
gentil alors on parle un petit peu
Mégane un tout petit peu ouais c'est la
merde pourquoi
bah c'est la marque parce que bah voilà
le duc qui a du CS2 Netflix revienne
ils vont recevoir
des défenses des droits de l'homme qui
descendra le 6 décembre prochain à New
York a pris à Mégane et Harry pour leur
engagement contre le racisme structurel
et ça Charles III le prend très mal
absolument parce que j'ai une grande
soirée donc il y aura lieu à l'hôtel
Hilton et alors c'est un peu particulier
parce que il reçoivent ce prix alors
c'est une organisation en effet qui est
voilà par le Lancia président financière
Sénator
Robert Fitzgerald de Kennedy c'est sa
fille qui a créé cette institution et le
but de cette institution chaque année
mais en lumière des acteurs qui ont
particulièrement un vrai dans le but
philanthropique humanitaire et dans le
droit dans le droit de la défense de
l'homme voilà et on apprend qu'il
reçoive donc ce prix le 6 décembre
prochain parce que Mégane nous dit-on à
un vrai contre le racisme au sein de
cette institution plus que centenaire
donc la famille royale pas choquant oui
et non ça veut tout simplement dire que
en acceptant ce prix bah à nouveau
Mégane et Harry remuent un peu
reconnaître que la monnaie le royaume en
effet il y a donc du racisme au sein
même de la famille royale ce qu'elle
avait dénoncé chez Oprah Winfrey en
disant qu'elle est vécu du racisme de la
part de la reine d'Angleterre donc elle
est en train de dire que oui il y a du
racisme
donc d'a-t-elle jouer Mégane en lui
demandant mais écoutez allez plus loin
dans vos propos aussi ils sont racistes
mais dites-nous exactement de qui il
s'agit et bien alors là elle ne répond
pas pour c'est la seule fois d'ailleurs
qu'elle n'accorde pas d'interview alors
qu'elle adore ça de façon à laisser
planer le doute sur l'ensemble de
l'institution royale donc vous vous
doutez bien que du côté de Charles III
bah ça passe pas trop bien parce que on
est au début d'un règne qui ne s'annonce
pas facile en effet donc on aimerait
voilà tenter de canaliser Harry et
Megane c'est pas chose faite puisqu'on
sait qu'il y a le documentaire Netflix
qui arrive il y a l'autobiographie du
prince Harry qui arrive également pour
lequel il était payé 20 millions de
dollars quand même on le rappelle et sur
il est gratignerait particulièrement bah
son père avec qui n'a jamais eu de très
bons rapports mais surtout Camilla qui
déteste véritablement et le fameux titre
de ce livre de cet autobiographie
d'ailleurs via de tomber de rechange
entre guillemets
de rechange donc c'est qui veut des
remplacer
alors pour ni le gardiener qui
commentateur de la monarchie c'est une
honte totale voilà effectivement qu'elle
reçoive ce prix là j'ai pensé à un truc
un jour surtout qui donne pas un matin
j'ai pensé à Spa de ma tête ce matin je
me lève et je me dis imagine-toi
William aurait épousé il sera tombé fou
amoureux d'une fille de couleur il y a
Ludivine par exemple à Paris Ludivine
hop ça accroche d'accord ils ont un
enfant l'enfant noir ça veut dire que le
prochain roi d'Angleterre aurait été
noir c'est comme ça que ça se passe
la réponse
quand même que Meghan Markle elle est
conduite à l'hôtel par le roi Charles
III est-ce que ça c'est du racisme
ou si oui je suis convaincu que ils sont
c'est une monarchie c'est une
institution qui ne cesse de se
moderniser et ils sont conscients que
s'ils ne se modernisent pas c'est
terminé pour eux l'arrivée de Meghan
Markle ils l'ont applaudi des deux mains
et ils se sont dit il y a enfin
quelqu'un qui va représenter les
minorités mais derrière elle a pas
accepté de jouer le jeu à fond elle est
partie un peu vite et là on va surtout
que ceux qui traduit aussi ce prix c'est
qu'ils ont besoin d'argent ils ont
besoin que l'on continue de parler d'eux
parce qu'il y a des commentateurs en
Angleterre ils disent on n'en peux plus
on en a marre ok Elisabeth II a retiré
le prédicat d'Altesse royale en revanche
ils sont encore duc et duchesse de ce
sexe Baron et baron compte et comtesse
de John Barton et sur cette carte là oui
mais vous êtes un peu technique
ils ont leurs armoiries royales qui ne
cesse de distribuer partout s'il n'avait
plus cette carte royale là on estime que
les contrats va pleuraient un peu moins
en tout cas les montants seraient
beaucoup moins avoir c'est où donne
parles
il y a un Castorama qui fait l'anglais
et qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire de toute
pognon quand même pardon mais une partie
de des droits de l'autobus biographie
soit disant votre reversé à des enfants
humanitaires parce que on n'a pas
consulté le contrat mais on n'a pas
vraiment vu c'est eux à nouveau qui nous
disent c'est voilà on prend on rappelle
aussi 99 millions de dollars touchés
pour le documentaire Netflix qui devrait
nous dit-on
sortira il est sera diffusé avant alors
que Harry de Me réalise veut surfer sur
ce Crown carton
normalement mais alors ça on le rappelle
que c'est la page la fameuse chronique
page 6 du New York qui révèle
normalement ce que page 6 révèle voilà
c'est cassis c'est tout le temps vrai
donc on attend on attend la Netflix n'a
pas encore acheté bah pourquoi parce
qu'il est dans la page ceci ah son
numéro 6
Bertrand et tu m'arrête si je dis des
bêtises mais en fait
toujours la reine mère elle avait quand
même un petit peu la tendue c'est à dire
Diana on a fait les fraises
sous son petit décorum comme ça bleu de
rager a été quand même un petit peu on
va dire un petit peu raide de temps en
temps avec Diana avec Charles etc etc
donc est-ce que il y aurait pas eu quand
même au sein de la famille royale
quelques on va dire
oui acte raciste on va dire si elle en a
peut-être souffert parce que elle disait
tu tu disais tout à l'heure finalement
en fait elle s'est exprimée mais comme
ça d'une manière un peu globale un peu
nébuleuse
dans un monde à part il y a eu et le
reste du monde
les avoir côtoyés tu sens tout de suite
qu'il y a une barrière que tu ne fais
franchiras
a demandé de quelle couleur va être le
bébé est-ce que c'est du racisme
de quelle couleur va être le bébé c'est
que tu as une petite inquiète pas du bon
et c'est peut-être simplement une
interrogation il y a un mari
est-ce que c'est du racisme de demander
mais de quelle couleur
globalement
la famille royale globalement il a ses
favori il a ses chouchou elle quand on
voit the crown je sais pas si vous
regardez
ils sont tous absolument au dieu mais
globalement ils sont tous
racistes conservateurs bien sûr profite
d'un d'une absolument hallucinante etc
pourquoi tu as des chouchous parmi
ceux-là et pourquoi il y en a il y en a
certains ou certaines que tu détestes tu
défonces ton temps je n'aime pas
tellement l'homme ou la femme qui va
dans la meuf qui représente la monarchie
j'aime la monarchie j'aime l'idée de la
Couronne et on parle des gens là
humainement continuité oui parce qu'il
la carne entre guillemets par rapport à
une Élisabeth II en tout cas on ne peut
pas haute enfin voilà on peut
difficilement ne pas reconnaître une
aura mais la vie mais comme le dit se
fit elle était tout sauf gentille
elisabether
un truc parce qu'on est en train de
faire un documentaire ensemble pour ces
buts qu'on adore sur Cher de 3 mais il
faut aussi te rendre compte quelque
chose de Laurent c'est que Charles III
on l'a fait Charles III tous les matins
on lui repasse c'est la seule chaussure
on lui met deux centimètres de
dentifrice sur la brosse à dents il a
pas de passeport il a pas de permis de
conduire il sort jamais de chez lui il
va pas faire de course et des
obligations tout le temps une voix
personne quel que soit la chose qu'il
dit on lui dit oui donc effectivement ça
donne des personnes qui sont
conservatrices
et qui n'ont rien vu d'autre que des
gens blanches chiants et tout comme eux
moi je lève le doigt hein
vous avez pas de mémoire tout ça parce
que quand Mégane c'est quand elle a été
présentée oui maintenant justement quand
elle a été présentée à la cour
d'Angleterre on a vu des images partout
il y a eu des tartines d'articles pour
dire que la reine a vu un coup de foudre
pour Mégane et qu'elle le faisait rire
et qu'elle s'entendait bien et il y a eu
des photos où elles ont des fous rires
toutes les deux alors faut savoir on est
à géométrie variable les choses évoluent
oui les rendez-vous
mais en effet une quête Middleton elle
doit attendre presque 9 ans avant de
pouvoir en effet faire en voyage à côté
de une méga
2 mois après Meghan Markle elle est à
côté de la reine donc en effet la reine
et l'institution royale ont montré
vis-à-vis de Meghan Markle une très
grande ouverture mais attends pardon
méga Kate c'est un mariage arrangé on le
sait comme Diana est à berger on l'a vu
dans une école on lui a dit que tu es
poudres
alors au moins Mégane c'est peut-être un
range c'était peut-être du deux fois
mais sur deux personnes qui sont aimés
toi même les mariages à ranger tes pour
je reconnais que tu es très conservateur
toi tu es vraiment conservateur du
conservateur c'est sûr que si méga n'ont
plus reprocher ce qu'on veut moi je la
défends toujours mais on peut leur
projet ce qu'on veut mais je pense pas
qu'elle soit complètement débile et
quand elle a fait des accusations de
racisme au sein de la couronne elle
savait très bien qu'il y a beaucoup plus
à perdre en disant ça qui a gagné c'est
qu'il y avait une vraie blessure
on me dit que là vraiment vraiment
énerve-toi garde tout en toi tout va
sortir
dîner de gala que j'adoffrir Buckingham
Palace et que je vois la sublime
princesse de Galles comme elle fait
diginement son job et qu'elle représente
les Anglais bah je me dis que peut-être
vous n'auriez pas de couper la tête à
vos rois mais ça n'engage que moi
Jean-Michel
République j'avais une petite question
pourquoi Charles III au temps de mal à
s'imposer la dernière sortie il a pris
des œufs sur la tête
en Angleterre
2 cm de ces chaussures il faut
reconnaître le service
incroyable en effet c'était dans le
cadre d'une visite où il inauguré
d'ailleurs une stature le nord de sa
mère qui a demandé 5 ans de préparation
dans le comité de York et en effet il a
eu des œufs parce qu'il y a quand même
des personnes qui revoilà qui sont
contre la monarchie il faut le savoir
aussi quand même ça existe oui bande de
petits appuis non mais très peu très
peur
non mais les abeilles c'est sympa la
monarchie qu'on aimait c'était Elisabeth
III documentaire mais j'ai découvert un
truc dans le documentaire qu'on a fait
lorsque Diana est morte et que forcément
les Anglais on aura plus voulu à Charles
parce qu'il l'a trompé donc Diana était
les voir ailleurs donc elle est morte
c'est un peu l'effet papillon mais voilà
et que et que ça avancé voilà le
cercueil avant c'est que les enfants
derrière et bien Charles portait un
gilet pare-balles
et du coup il sera tu et dans les mois
qui vont suivre c'est Camilla qui on va
vouloir ça absolument plus sortir Diana
n'a pas fait non
quand même voilà pour la monarchie aussi
constituée quand même un petit souci ben
voilà ça c'était le dernier coup voilà
attends vous les voyez maintenant moi je
vous trouve très très dur pour le
printemps parce que honnêtement ce type
qui n'a pas été aimé étant petit café
comme il pouvait et qui maintenant
maintenant est roi a un vrai engagement
écolo pardon mais qui n'est pas
inintéressant et il vit une immense
histoire d'amour avec une femme
elle était jeune elle était franchement
pas vilaine et maintenant on la voit
maintenant évidemment
ne voulait pas le job et qui exactement
jamais je ne veux pas entrer là où je
dis une toute petite parenthèse
concernant William et Kate pourquoi
parce qu'elle savait très bien qu'elle
épousa en job en épousant William elle
savait très bien qu'elle épousait une
institution à savoir la couronne c'est
dans ce cadre là que je suis pour les
mariages avant moi je suis sûr qu'il
s'aime les deux hein c'est pas possible
c'est vraiment on est au bal tour avec
la face de frein hein
est-ce que tu t'imagines la team qu'il
forme mon cœur j'ai un très beau cadeau
de Noël une couronne ah là là qu'est-ce
que c'est ça vraiment
regarde la photo de 1987
c'est une biographie qui n'est pas une
biographie c'est un cri du coeur c'est
une déclaration d'amour dans lequel je
vous propose le lecteur une expérience
et je leur dis voilà on fait magie d'un
livre on fait comme si la reine n'était
pas morte je vous emmène avec moi
suivez-moi pendant 15 jours on va vivre
à côté d'Elizabeth mais non donc
j'emmène le lecteur de la lectrice sur
tout Déborah le ciel dans le dressing
d'Elisabeth II aussi mille tailleur au
6000 chapeaux ou 6000 parapluies
volières qui ont été imaginés tous
spécialement il avait écrit avant je
termine le livre le 1er septembre
Danemark le 8 donc mon éditeur dit on
arrête tout on ne se précipite pas on on
sera le premier ouvrage complet donc
j'inclus les obstacles les funérailles
la rencontre entre Harry Megane les
couples de nous dans le livre et je
parle de vous
cadeau de Noël offrait merci beaucoup
cher Bertrand d'avoir été avec nous